okay
Jennifer four is uh will be your
researcher she's upstairs presenting the
30 page side-by-side to House Education
right now
um but we're also going to have Brad
Greenland who's right behind me and
Brad's going to be the other researchers
so
um Gen 4 and Brad will be assisting your
committee and uh we're doing two
researchers actually the whole staff
because we all have a vested interest in
helping you any way we can and then your
committee assistant is Jamie Wyman who's
right here and Jamie just started
um this January and she might might as
well have been here 10 years she's been
right she got she just came right in the
thick things and has been great since
she arrived um Jamie is in and is in
your uh binder she's in room 301 and her
extension is 3125. and of course Brad
and Jen they're on the fourth floor with
the rest of us
so the first thing that I want to
mention
um is I sent you a corrected or I
delivered to all of you this morning I
corrected uh special committee on
commission's membership and staff
listing because I had a member's name
wrong but it has um all the members
there now and it has your meeting room
which is 104 and then it has the
researchers as well as Jamie with the
numbers so you can reach anybody and
they'll be able to help you
um and I asked so as president Dylan
mentioned
we received a couple of questions
regarding things and we said well
um Deborah and I thought that would
probably be helpful if we could walk you
through the binder because you know
sometimes you just get we know what it
is but also you say oh
can someone help me figure out what all
this material is is about so that's why
I thought it'd be helpful to walk you
through it unfortunately
um I told Deborah that we didn't we
didn't both have to be here that I could
walk us you all through this and if she
has um or you have any questions
um
just feel free to call either one of us
so your first section on committee was
where we had done the membership in
staff and then the committee on
commissions the
the problem statement the special
committee's charge
um Deborah went over that when we did
our um
our slide uh presentation last week the
PowerPoint but that's all listed right
there for YouTube
um review or access as you're looking
back figuring out why where you're doing
what you're doing
the next uh listing is the relevant
statutes and house rules so this comes
from our office house key services and
the most important obviously is RSA 1449
which oversees
um
the the aspect of the legislative study
committee and commissions and this was
amended last year to make those uh what
we think are significant changes which
includes that no commission shelled more
than 15 members and may include
employees who are not members of general
court but that the majority are our
members of the um
the general court and that the
appointment for the members is
coterminous with their term in office
um
so
so that status right there and then
um house rule 37 which refers to the
chapter study committee duration and
membership
so those are two there are other some
other statutes that may apply
and some other rules but these are the
major
um house this is Major house Rule and
statute that applies to the commissions
um the next one are the initiatives
we staff pull together
um
highlights of
what we thought were significant and
we're going to go we can go back Beyond
93 but I think I mentioned last week we
thought 30 years
was a pretty good perspective but you
can see that's that is start off that's
when um 1449 was enacted in 93 and
initially was thought to help curb these
studies and then in 1995 the OLS
director
had a memo which I can get a copy to you
but both the house and sudden leadership
met and before this we never had the
boilerplate language regarding reports
due by November 1 and that they're
supposed to go to the governor said a
present speaker they just went anywhere
and they were just a hodgepodge of
whatever so there was a this was not
obviously done through legislation it
was just a joint agreement and a memo
from the OLS director stating
moving forward that that information had
to be included in every single
um study committee report
but a sidebar as that stuff goes astray
is when
uh
a term or two terms down the road a new
Senator came in and said why do we have
to here to adhere to November one I want
December one and that's how things begin
to change
so uh in 09 House Bill 2 that's where
this original the Lori Harding study
commission
um started and that's and you can see it
um
they reviewed everything and
non-regulatory committees uh created by
state law because the regulatory
committees have a different role and we
we don't over uh see those obviously
um when they met
um what their goals were
um and how they filed legislation to
eliminate duplicative outdated or
um
or unnecessary committees
um the suggested PL of 62 committees and
they completed that process in by 2010
and 2011.
and then in 2010 they had another
committee I think this was
um an offshoot of 09 and they continued
that was part of the cleanup process
that they went through to get rid of all
of those uh suggested 62 committees
um
yes that's that was that was the
initiative for 2010 and 2011 we'd have
to look up every single one to make sure
they were there might have been
an argument why one or two weren't but
yes it was a bulk a huge a huge bulk of
them and I would say probably all of
them
um and then in uh
wait what years and then in 2011 we also
had house rule 37g
um which we we added um
any study commute Commission test for
any other like entity creative
authorized by chapter lost shall file
its report and dissolved by November 1st
of the second year only legislators
shall be members of such entities that
was
um
that was to include
um that we we thought that this was a
good inclusion
um from the restrictions from 1449 we
wanted that in the house in the house
rule as well
um in 2019
that was uh representative Evil's first
um study commission you can see all the
bullets that are there the work they
they did in that and then the subsequent
2020 and 2022.
um those are the highlights of work that
we've done I think last week I didn't
bring it down today but I have a
expandable file about this big with all
the suggestions even though this lists
the highlights
we staff and and legislative have worked
on
a variety of suggestions to leadership
on on how we could do this and um
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
um
so we just wanted to this is just the
highlights and stuff going into all that
detail and all the anecdotal situations
so you could see the efforts that were
put in uh before
um the next piece which is the past
committee on committee reports
um you can see this is the report of the
first one is the 2010 one of
Representative Harding
um and this is the work that was done on
Um this can be also lists everything
that they went through and have the the
actual report is uh only the first
um 10 pages the appendix's appendices
has have all the um
committees that were removed or how how
they moved how they uh tried to get rid
of um the ones that they weren't
that just weren't functioning
the next report represents evil it's
January 2020.
um January 30th 2020 then we have
following one November 1 2020 so we have
for House Bill 4-1 then her house bill
um
and then
she she is going to be the best one to
walk you through all of this because she
knows this off the top of her head and
as I mentioned we can also see if Pam
could come in and meet with you to walk
you through some of this but
representative people having to share
this and and representative is the type
of chair who is totally immersed in the
process so that's the one in that's in
spreadsheet format
yes
well it says current committees and
commissions you've got the tab this no
this one is the tab is pass committee on
committee reports
oh got it okay yeah
um but I think I think it again she will
be the best one to walk you through that
um the current committees and
commissions
um that has the listing of
joint The Joint legislative statutory
that first listing those are all
committees that have to exist their
legislative
um committees and
we actually when they looked at 2010
they did bring all those committees
before them but those are just the
Committees that exist
um so that we can
um function and then obviously have
capital budget administrative rules
dedicated funds but those are considered
um joint legislative statutory
committees but we also have so if I was
to say how many
current committees there are that's the
job to go to and just count them all up
um no not yet we're going to be adding
to that Deborah's going to be getting
the spreadsheet for all of you that that
spreadsheet is going to be a different
spreadsheet this one just has the joint
legislative ones right now but that
spreadsheet will be coming as we
finalize that that's the one
where every office so my office the
clerk's office uh my counterpart in the
senate senate clerk's office Deborah and
the Senate president's office everybody
had maintained a separate spreadsheet of
all 200 because we all have different
um
needs so what happened was Deborah
met with it and they're developing
um a brand new spreadsheet that we can
all have access to and we will all have
the exact same information so that is
what we're working on so that's why that
this will be coming but in the meantime
we will get a spreadsheet
um so you will have something to work
from but again it's going to help with
representative to
um put those pieces of the puzzle
together because there may be some on
there
um that she'll know the reason why
they're in existence even if they
haven't met and I think it will be
helpful too if we get the questionnaires
for you to see how we sent those
questionnaires out in the past and
she'll be able to explain how that
process went
um the questionnaires I thought
were really helpful because they'll
explain like
how can that you be named to that child
care commission hasn't met for 11 years
I wonder what they explained to the
the commission
and so she may be able to to fill you in
on what why that was done that way
um
the the next piece is
the study committee process we explain
how people organize
out of the first named it has to
organize their committee
we have a study Community share
responsibilities
and then we have this chart that we
designed for you called comparison study
creation study elements and this has
the legislative
what the process is you can see it's
multi-colored we thought we put it in
color it would be easy to see and you
can see how if you start out with the
start out with the statutory commission
all the steps you have to go through to
create one a chaptered study is similar
but um as you can see retained Bill gets
less interim study and ad hoc
has very um very few steps but as we
know every one of these entities does
conducts a study
it's just that
um the different steps that one has to
go through and obviously the
the the ones that take the most time are
statutory and chapters statutory in
particular because of all of the
appointments and chapters today because
it goes through the whole process house
senate and then and then it has to be um
signed off by the governor
um
the next
tab
are samples and what what we did the
first
three letters are the samples of the
appointments letters that the speaker
makes and that
um Deborah
has to get the letters together and send
the appointments out
to um wherever they have to go now as
you saw last week Deborah has this
binder with many people would like a
copy of us about that's what this is
it's all filled with these letters
and we we will get calls we're getting
calls now how come I'm still laying for
appointments for this Commission because
besides doing everything else the
speaker has to that's always the first
shock for the speaker when they arise
what do you mean I have to make like 400
appointments that that's part of the job
um
so
those are samples of the letters that
are sent out
[Music]
um
the next one is Paul from the house
flirt and
um this uh
is how Paul notifies our clerk's office
notifies the different agencies that
they must make an appointment
and he wanted to show you what
um that looks like and so he has to send
out to all those entities that are
listed
the next one is from my office
um
we designed in
1991 we designed this template because
before this reports were any which way
and what would drive us crazy wouldn't
have the year on it wouldn't have the
chapter law or the bill number and we we
need all that to um
to file it or find out that the report
was
um the community worked so anyway we did
this letter of transmittal it was
actually designed by a former member
representative um
Gary cowanhoven God Rest us all he he
did designed this for a big study he had
done and we've we've stuck with this
ever since then and then the next page
um he did a lot of transmissible at
transmittal and the researchers we
created the um template for the report
itself to make sure that the commission
charge is in there the study purpose the
proposition on the process and
procedures so that anybody who goes if
you're looking back at a report from 10
years ago you can see oh this is how
they organize and this is
um
how they got to where where they decided
for their um
in the end if they have proposed
legislation or what their final
conclusions are it's right there and and
it's easy for people to see so we
thought a similar format for every
report would help people
um
the pictures which you saw last week on
the screen our report Library this
is is we have a closet in my office and
uh these hold all the reports and this
doesn't even include all the reports
that step in the Attic of the LOB
so often
um
at the conclusion of report we send it
out to those other sources or the uh
where we mentioned that the clerk's the
speaker the Senate President the
governor at the State library and then
we keep a copy here if we're involved
with the study sometimes we're not
involved at all even if it's a House
member the house member does everything
on their own and never even comes to our
office to ask her any assistance and
sometimes we reach out and they'll say
nope we're all set
so that that can occur because there's
no
as we've mentioned before these studies
are on their own they can they can
pretty much do what they want they have
to follow the right to know but they
don't report to the speaker or the
Senate President
um
they can if it's a member members
usually try to stay involved with us but
there are those occasions and especially
if it's another outside group with the
chairman with an outside group
um they don't necessarily come back to
us for assistance and this came up in
our initial discussion uh last week
uh what would
why wouldn't we want to be able to take
all the the current
study
commissions and map them into committee
chairman
uh to say okay you're a committee
chairman you're the committee chairman
for Edna
you've got these 18 study commissions
that are alive and well alive maybe
they're not well they're alive
and it's your job to manage them and we
all have to Define what that means by
managing them but what would what's
wrong with that concept I
I from a staff perspective I don't see a
problem with it at all it's one way to
follow
what's going on I think again
representative evil can explain if they
want to I do know that representative
umberger and represent people they both
were working together with legislative
Administration with a lot of suggestions
last year and and I represent umberger
told me that was one of her plans she
was going she want
to suggest something like that because
for instance one of the issues is take
House Education and they have the public
higher ed study commission well that's
been around forever and they look at
obviously public higher ed and then
another a member brought in a bill to
look at the college the public College
University system to have a study
commission to look at that well you
already have one so that would be nice
for the chairman of the committee
to to see that um
to explain or just in that way my
thought that that way it wouldn't matter
who who had the leadership in the in the
house
no matter which side it went to which
party you went to that the same
pedigree of chairman would still have
oversight maybe the chair the name of
the chairman would change but say hey
you just you're going to be take you're
going to be the new chairman of of Edna
and hear your 22
committees to look after and they and I
think as part of that that's me talking
not the committee but think of part of
that it's that new chairman might go
through that and says we don't need all
these we need we can get rid of half a
dozen of these then then that would
start with a cleansing process if you
will to some degree
with change of priority
I I think that that's obviously I'm up
for the committee to to look at but
that's something I know when I stopped
how said a long time ago I used to
prepare a list on my own for the chairs
every time a new chair came in and said
oh by the way these 10
statutories all fall under you
and and then even know that um but then
you change you change chairs I know
representative Vlad is on top of it but
you could get a new chair in-house said
who it's like what do you mean actually
we did one year in my game was I said I
have no idea they have 10 other
committees that I have to pay attention
to so
um that is a good way to to follow it
but sometimes there are those
commissions that don't connect to I
would imagine if we did something like
that it would be some orphans
that nobody wants to claim to that's not
I don't want that that's not then those
become
I would think
Prime candidates to get rid of if nobody
wants them no nobody wants to claim them
then we then we'd have to look for
sponsors to say hey this is a good idea
this committee really needs to be
retained or kept in in uh
in existence and then make sure it gets
assigned to a committee chair that
actually takes it and runs with it
I really appreciate this conversation
because I think it is unclear which I
think you know which which of these uh
committees both you know go to each of
the statutory committees and I wonder
I wonder if there can be
rather than
you know committee chairs claiming them
I wonder if we need to go through the
process of formally assigning and saying
these fit under you know each of the
each of the statuary committees or
making some decisions because there may
be some where there's an intersection
between Health and Human Services and
education for example
um
I also just cognizant of how much work
that is for in this case German lad
right like 10 of these different
committees wonder if there's a role for
the clerk on the committee to to play in
that or you know I think there's some
different ways we could design it but
um wouldn't want to leave it up to the
committee chairs to decide because
ultimately you know they're inheriting
those they're kind of being stewards of
that work for the to your term and
um
I think I think there needs to and who
knows maybe it could be an ongoing
committee like this that is you know
continuing to kind of do the maintenance
and uh just making sure that
um expectations are clear and I know
from observing uh how
Carol Maguire does the manages her
committee she has I think four different
subcommittees
then when a particular issue it's
difficult comes up
he assigned it to a subcommittee to to
go work it and then bring back a
solution to the full committee as
opposed to trying to do it all or itself
uh which seems to be a model that could
be uh
excuse me
right I was
for us I'm sorry and you did you have
more that you wanted to yeah I was just
good I was just going to take you
through the rest of the binder and then
please do it I just um I um
so the the next page is
this uh was our so we have that web page
which I was showing representative Dolan
Ripley was she and before the um
before we started if you go on the
general court webpage and you go all the
way to the bottom there's a ribbon
um and it's under helpful links it'll
say
statutory slash study committee so
that's what it says Brad
I think statutory whatever it says it's
the second one down and anyway once you
link onto that
um it will it will
you plug in a keyword and it'll bring up
without a study you're looking for and
we also have archive studies in there
but the next there's another link
we don't do this for every committee we
do it if they request it some committees
wish to have their own committee web
page beyond that and so we've designed
that in this first page that I'm showing
you the New Hampshire citizens trade
policy commission this is just a sample
this was the old web page and this was
designed by
um Patrick Murphy and the senate in
Senate research and we all love this so
much our the house took on this style as
well so how staff because the way it was
laid out it's very easy to find
legislation calendar notices agendas
minutes membership and that was our our
style
um and so for instance Exotic Aquatic
weeds which has now been around for 25
plus years that was the layout that we
use so former representative Suzanne
Smith will send her information to our
office from that study commission then
we send it over to it and they wouldn't
plug it in when we had the new revamp of
our general court webpage page because
of how they pulled everything in
the new style is the second page where
it says joint Community dedicated funds
as you can see it's just
a listing of
everything you can find the individual
reports we want to
re we as staff want to go back to the
old design we're going to work with them
because we just think it's easier to
read
but we thought we wanted to show you the
previous
um document and the previous web page in
the current one which um
just has a list of all the information
we like to have as much electronic
information up there as possible so that
members of the public can access or
members can access whatever they need
but we're working on that as well so we
want to redesign it and get it back to
the old
um Style
and then the final item is the glossary
of terms as we were as you you heard us
we throw on all these terms
um like what chapter studies statutory
non-regulatory so what we decided to do
was put together a glossary of terms for
you
so
um
and you can read because someone has
said wouldn't it be nice if we had a
list of all the terms that are used in
this process and it was a member who who
inquired about that and that's when we
said wait a minute we already did this
and that's how Deborah and I thought you
know what maybe we ought to walk
everybody through the binder so they'll
know what's in there so you can see that
just lists the terms and the then we
broke it down into groupings of the
different offices are involved in the
process the relevant statutes the study
committee types
um and we did bullets we couldn't just
do we tried to do one sentence
descriptions then we realized no we have
to have bullets under each item to
explain
um
uh exactly in Greater detail what each
term refers to
so so that that was it um regarding
the binder and then we did some
um
updates I was going to ask um Brad and
Jamie if they could pass this out
um
this one is the number of
um active studies we did a an exercise
from 0-1 to 2022.
and we did a chart Brad had put this
together were you PM smarling did the
initial one and then Brad updated it and
then this is the current amount we have
um these are Commissions in existence
right now we have this one broken down
by um thanks Jamie and it's broken down
by committee for you Brad put that
together as well
for you so you can see
what the numbers are right now what the
subject matter is
um
again is uh
I'm a disposition standpoint it might be
a question for Paul Smith and is the
let's say that we want to get rid of a
study convention
that one that the the Vanessa was
talking about earlier that hadn't met
since 2011. let me see that one's we're
going to get rid of it and we all agree
that's what we're going to do what is
the the right is the right way to do it
is to repeal it through your legislation
yes so you have to repeal it we'd have
to bring forth a bill a new bill that
says we go to OLS and say we want to
repeal this and they'd come up with the
language
so when I was telling you about the
former majority leaders who had done
that that's what they did they just put
in they they created legislation we can
get copies of from years ago that listed
them but also representative Harding's
commission and representative evil they
put in legislation too
we talked about Senator Sherman had a
pfas
study going on that hasn't met in a long
long time but he probably doesn't he I
would imagine he probably doesn't want
to be associated with killing the pfas
study that his maybe on some of his
constituents really want to see happen
but
nothing's happening on it so let's say
let's play this out the house we put
some legislation in that kills it
can't the Senate
just refuse to accept that and was it to
stay alive yes so that's the potential
issue we have with with uh repealing
legislation is the Senate doesn't agree
then it just stays indefinitely Or until
some other action is taken
yes
that's that is that has happened uh
before or as I said that the legislation
comes in they'll say notwithstanding
um
whatever we've we've generous I said the
said I know the senator and I I loved
her to death the one who changed the
November one she'd been in the house she
met she got
then she was Senate she left Senate came
back and she was the one who said what's
November one
deadline I don't like this I'm changing
December one and then once she did that
then another Senator did and and the
problem is with the December 1 deadline
is that
um we have a new we have the election we
always like the November one because it
was a firm date was before the election
but if it's it's the problem
when you um go into the next biennium
and you have
um to replace those members and that has
happened all of a sudden we have a
deadline date that that goes beyond
um
you're swearing in deadline and then
also we have all new members we have to
wait for the speaker to reappoint and
we'll they say well no we're getting
ready to have our final report of
December 15th it's like well there are
no members those numbers are no longer
that must become doubly difficult when
if you get a new speaker yes
because you have people knocking at his
or her door saying we're we're um
where where the we need this right away
but every everything needs to be
appointed right away
anyone else have any questions for Ryan
watches it yeah
I don't have a question I just want to
comment on how much I appreciate the the
thoroughness and this is the perfect
balance of
information because I know you know we
could probably fill multiple binders
with this
but as somebody just walking into this
relatively blind I feel like you've
given us exactly what we need to to hit
the ground running so thank you so much
for doing such a phenomenal job thank
you to you and your staff thank you
thank you very much and I want to say
thank you very much for all you're doing
you press to stop this you saw the staff
last week and we are we're very happy
and excited about all the work you're
going to be doing
huh
yes representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much for everything thank
the staff also I'm still trying to
figure out if there's a commission that
exists currently that hasn't been
terribly active that's been on the verge
of repeal from what I read this week in
over and over again
and if we decide this commission should
be repealed but the people really want
to exist under some thing
do you have any concept of how we can
help guide a group if we don't want them
to be a commission under law I'll tell
you what I'm talking about and they're
very upset about it there's been a lot
in the newspapers about the New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs
and they do do an annual report but they
haven't been awfully active they're
scared to death that if the repeal
that's been threatened several times
actually occurs what will they do do we
have any sense of direction to help them
be organized and do what they feel they
want to do without having them be a
commission well
so
um again I would refer to representative
Ebel because of what because they they
have the groups come before them explain
why they need to exist
but one of the things that we did
recognize and it's something I think
maybe you could put on your list of
items to consider
is that as I mentioned representative
Gary cowanhoven who had done that first
study it was on um you hear you knew you
knew Gary Right Gary Cowan open
um it was on EMTs because he was an EMT
and an emergency services
anyway so we'd start out as a
legislative study and
um they did a wonderful report they had
all these um ideas but they didn't
create legislation from it what they did
was they created
um HHS created their own entity and and
legislators weren't on that anymore and
that became part of the um agency's
Endeavor
um and that's sometimes what people do
it doesn't necessarily have to be there
may be a legislator involved initially
but once the work gets going and they
don't really need legislative oversight
they can create their own entity within
their department or agency
and then we had another one a few years
ago that was just all Commissioners they
had been meeting as an informal group
and decided that they wanted to
formalize as a group which they did and
we didn't have a legislative appointment
to that and they just exist
on their own somewhere
so thank you very much I just wondered
if there was precedent for something
like this how a group or an entity can
become something other than a commission
so thank you you're welcome
um so any any questions Jennifer and um
Gen 4 and Brad will be here at the
meetings and anything you need from any
of the staff any question on anything we
will come running just like that any
assistance we can give you you will give
to us
so thank you so much and thank you for
um the opportunity to get you to talk
with you about this all again and
I'm sure we're going to run into a
number of questions that we're going to
be stumped yeah
thank you and also stop up um never
hesitate to stop up on the fourth floor
um just stop and see us and and we can
help you with any any questions you have
okay thank you very much thanks
all right um
we left last week's meeting with within
at least the initial thought
that perhaps we would ask
ourselves to think of splitting up into
groups and trying to take this in pieces
one group
I thought makes sense is a process group
what is the process and we have a good
notebook to help uh guide us with that
but
but also that would serve as a
as a primer for
new legislatures legislative doors uh
new freshmen that that come in to try to
figure out
the lay of the land and so forth and
what's going on and that would help
serve that purpose as well but a process
group is to
uh what do we do with a with a
commission that
Vanessa was was before the meeting
started had an example that hadn't met
since 0-1 I think
um
and we already know that one of the
excuses
I I use that term loosely is that well
it was covet
well this we haven't had covert around
since 2001 so it must be something other
than covid that's caused that group to
stop meeting and so what do we do what's
the first step once when something we
recognize a problem
uh of non-meeting what happens next and
that then we would I think look to the
this process subcommittee to say okay
the first thing to do is
bring the
chairman in and question the chair and
find out you know is it what's really
the problem here or is there a problem
or the chair might come in and say I
don't think we need this anymore or we
really do need it but we can't get
anybody to show up whatever the issue is
we investigate that and then as a
committee we make it a decision that's
what the disposition of that committee
uh that committee ought to be and then
we've we have to understand the reality
that we've got to get that through
uh the house leadership to agree that
whatever action we're going to take is
the the right action and we have to also
live in the real world that we have a we
have another organization called the
Senate and we need to probably if we're
going to take some action we need to
probably
consult with somebody over on that side
of the of the wall to say hey this is
coming are you guys going to fight it
are you going to embrace it because if
they're going to fight it it's it's
going to be a dead end street because
they can just kill it and then we don't
make any progress unless we want to just
make a state
which I I think is kind of a waste of
time but you know that that'll be up to
us as a group so
if we split into
I'm thinking three groups
one group for process
another another two groups to say hey uh
this
you take these 10 commissions or you
take these 20 commissions and go through
them the way Karen did uh and the last
time she had the had the uh the Baton
and come back to this group and make
some recommendations to keep the
commission disband it or investigate it
or let's
these 10 commissions we think that three
need to be killed seven need to be
investigated and we're gonna schedule
those seven to come before us and
testify as to as to what their status is
and why they want to continue or not
continue
uh so I I lay that out to you all as a
as a as a loose process if you will uh
to get get to get started into and start
digging into the meat of of the tasks we
had before us does anybody have any
thoughts or any comments about that
everybody was in a wall so thank you Mr
chairman um a lot of this overlaps
some of what you mentioned in the
process also has to do with dissolution
of some of these or repeals of some of
these commissions I almost think where
it's not an awfully large group that we
have
that we almost ought to work together
because some of this will overlap I'm
thinking again as I went through it this
weekend
I saw different commissions come up over
and over again possible repeal or not
and um
we I'm just thinking if we work on
process for example and have a separate
group work on that in the group working
whether or not that something ought to
be repealed
the group work in something possible
or possible repeal may very well
have a totally different opinion from us
or US whoever we would be working on the
process wouldn't it make sense for us
all to work together
well you
I I do get your point what I'm concerned
about is
we've been asked by uh
house leadership to come forth
by the end of the year with some pretty
strong recommendations and I'm looking
at the calendar and we've got
basically I'm a month and a half before
we take a break
I guess uh middle middle to the end of
June is when we're going to shut shut
things down
um
and we can stock back up again as early
as we want but I'm just thinking we're
going to run out of time before we have
anything really meaty that we can we can
put on the table yes
thank you Mr chair I was wondering
representative wall if if we flipped it
if we started by going through
what exists and what our thoughts might
be initially in terms of repeal or
whether that means starting with
categorizing by statutory committee like
touched on
and then then after that come up with
the process for the actual repeal
because we'll have a better sense of
if they're themes of the kinds of of
committees that we're looking to repeal
um
you know what I was thinking working
together as a whole to begin with and
then when we see we might need to break
to figure out a problem divide into
groups of that point to more efficiently
and effectively get something done it
was a little frustrated as I read this
and I saw recommendations made for
how commissions should be developed and
put into law and what the details should
be and I I was disappointed to see that
over and over recommendations have been
made but that haven't been followed
and that fits into the process aspect of
this into what I said last week about
the need for continuing education the
need for chairman and vice chairman and
clerks to be involved from the very
beginning knowing what responsibilities
they have as well as for orientation but
then we have that whole gap of members
who have been here for a while
who either haven't ever had experience
for one reason or another
um either helping to form a commission
or serving on one and what do we do
about them
right I'm thinking uh thank you for that
I'm thinking
accountability is a key issue that and
that's why I was talking about mapping
to committee chair
that somebody needs to be held account I
I don't it's I think unacceptable to say
that we've heard the stories that's an
important thing but don't appoint me to
it that's a lack of accountability and
that if if a committee chairman
really thinks this this is an important
thing to do and he has to be held or she
has to be held accountable
to the rest of us
as legislators that uh
I'm going to manage this I'm going to
oversee it or I'm going to make sure
people attend and this lack of
accountability I think is is one of the
root causes of the problem that we're
facing and that that's why I thought
that was an important thing it's part of
our process to look at that that mapping
is probably an early step
and then once we do that if if we were
to do that I'm sure there's going to be
some orphans that are going to drop out
that that don't map into any
don't clearly map into any chairman or
maybe map into two or three because
because of the
the nature of the subject matter then
we've got to pick one say all right this
goes to three different chairmen but
you're going to be the lead on this and
we'll have to get somebody probably more
important than us to decide that that's
how it's going to be but but that would
be our recommendation and then if things
don't happen
than this someone to turn to to say why
didn't this happen the way it was
supposed to I'm not interested in it no
you can't say that because you are the
one being held accountable if you don't
if you don't think this is important
then let's put in legislation to kill it
get rid of it or change it to something
else that you do think is important
but
um I'm certain I think that's a that's a
fine idea to maybe work on the process
together for a while and then switch
our methodology over to in individual
commissions themselves yes thank you and
as you were talking I was thinking
um many of us have been appointed to one
thing or another over time and we will
often receive a notice saying first name
member will call the commission for
example together
and it's not the chairman of the
community
um of the house committee or the senate
committee
um it's that first name Person calls no
that doesn't mean that person has to
chair
but at least they call the meeting and
maybe we need to clarify that a little
bit too thank you right yeah and that
whole process discussion that's I think
that's that's part of the up up front
process and that maybe part of the
process that in the first meeting well
within the first couple of meetings a
chair is elected and a vice chair is
elected or whatever are chosen and that
then you move from there
I like that and that goes along with
your whole issue of accountability also
because someone has to get up and
running and doing something thank you
right and if if
the issue of of it being coterminous
that these appointments are coterminous
if somebody
doesn't get reelected then that becomes
a very uh visible opportunity for a
changeover or a switch or maybe even
eliminating it because because of that
but again it would drop back to the
committee chair to decide oh I'm going
to have to appoint somebody else the
feeling that this the seat that that
person didn't get reelected
re-elected to
and and that's why as you read through
this you'll see that it's very important
that we have sun setting Provisions as
well as dates for final reports uh
making it so that at the end of the
two-year term
um
things have to happen
um you either have to repeal or you have
to establish a process to go forward
because as we I read in here when you
have that Gap when you have someone who
isn't re-elected it causes the
commission or the committee to become
relatively ineffective for a while until
people get their feet wet and get going
again and that's part of the reason why
some of these drag on thank you
right
um
and like I was saying to uh Vanessa
earlier that I would personally be
skeptical to just blatantly uh
blankenly accept covet as the reason why
it should it should continue because we
just
we couldn't meet well again if it's a
this is 2011 is the is the important
date I think that's an empty excuse to
say covid because we've been haven't had
coveted what 2019 or 2020 so yeah yeah I
want to point out I mean covet is still
a thing right you know I I think your
your point though right is that that
shouldn't be the reason that the
committee is not right not meeting or
commission's not being right right I
I yeah Mr chair thanks I I uh I'm trying
to think about process for us and and
the work that we have ahead and trying
to think through you know and it was a
nice exchange between representative
wall and representative Rambo about
sort of what what should come first
whether we dig into the uh you know kind
of looking at all the different
commissions and trying to figure out
which ones you know may need to be
sunsetted or you know what kind of
recommendations to make there versus the
work of
um establishing some standards for for
commissions and
I'm just I'm trying to think through
what's the most
effective way to you know if one should
come first if we because I think there's
a lot that we we know already and that's
thanks to the staff and and their
presentations but also probably a lot
that we don't know and a lot of unique
things that each of these commissions
are facing
um or reasons that commissions are
really effective or reasons that they're
not uh reasons that they're meeting
reasons why they're not
um and so I wonder if there might be a
way for us to solicit some information
from the chairs of those commissions or
members of those commissions or you know
our colleagues who establish those
commissions in the first place
um that would help guide our work not
just in you know both both pieces both
figuring out what changes need to be
made to the existing commissions and you
know setting up process moving forward
so I throw that out there
as a a possible you know kind of interim
step here where we don't have to choose
one or the other but just suggesting
that we we may not have all the
information quite yet
yes ma'am
Matt do you think
we can in effort to use time wisely we
could sort of simultaneously solicit
feedback while maybe working on mapping
to statutory committees I just I keep
coming back to that as seeming like a
good starting point
to be able to go through the list when
we have the full list and trying to tag
them to the standing committees I know
they won't be perfect but in fact that's
something you can do with the outset and
then
if we don't get feedback maybe we didn't
go to those chairs of those committees
to solicit some feedback
um
I don't know just seems like that
it seems like a concrete first step I
don't know if other people think that
should happen later but good point let
me ask our assistants
uh
do you guys think that you could look at
our binders and be able to help us do
that mapping to say here's
you know here are the here are the
commissions and here's what they map to
and and when it's not clear in your mind
you just
make a guess or maybe a response is I
have no idea if you can't tell or
whatever and that would be in a
reasonable response but to bring us back
that list uh it doesn't have to be a
flowchart but just you know a kind of a
spreadsheet here are the commissions
here's who they map to
um
and that would that would beautiful
you know some people away cracking
what communities yes
well
that that's one way to look at it one
way to look at it would be what current
committee is managing it or as it
acknowledges it uh for example the
the agricultural committee
must have a certain number of of uh
study committees that it's that fall
into that subject matter and
if you could identify those for us then
we then we can go to the agricultural
committee chair and say do you recognize
this as yours and see if they move the
head up and down or back and forth and
then we then we kind of take the next
step all right if you don't recognize
the jewels we need to maybe again as we
develop our process maybe we need to go
to the speaker and the minority leader
and say
this is something obviously is important
you know do you agree that this is
something that the that the committee
chair ought to be uh managing or you
know at least overseeing and if as long
as the head keeps going up and down then
we can pursue that but if they say no we
don't
that really belongs over in Edna not
agriculture okay we'll have to sort
those things out
yeah representative walls thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much
um yeah some of the groundwork for that
has been laid out in here already and if
they can separate that out and carry it
a little further
that would be really helpful
um and I'll simply up the reason I keep
bringing up the um I have to keep
forgetting the official name New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs uh um I worked at length last
week we it was suggested we worked with
Myla and I I worked with her at length
because I remember testifying on the
original bill that came in and we found
all kinds of information that was
helpful to bring us up to date but we
could not find that original bill that
established the study committee
um initially what happened was and I
cannot for the life of me and I'm sure
somewhere in my files at home I have it
I was not a sponsor I just happened to
meet people out here in the hall one day
who wanted help
um
it all started out with the abernakis
wanting to be recognized as a tribe in
New Hampshire
and I thought
why not I mean they were sitting out
here making baskets they were beautiful
they were talking about going to powwows
and how all other states in New England
had recognized tribes so they could sell
their baskets and whatever else they
were making as their artifacts from
their tribes but in New Hampshire or
wherever these abernakis went they could
not say they said the Abenaki like or
Native American alike they preferred it
by the way to be called Indians at that
point but so I thought gee you know if
they're going to these powwows why
shouldn't they be able to do this
and what happened in the Senate was
shocking
to me all of a sudden floodgates opened
we're going to have to return all their
artifacts that our state archaeologist
Howard Sergeant found years ago and
cataloged and Captain a Barney had built
for them and sold to Harvard and this
that and the other and they're going to
want those back they're going to want
their lands back they're going to want
um the sacred territories and burial
sites back they're going to want
recompense from the federal government
so it went beyond what we could do here
therefore in order to do something to
help these people and I'm sorry it takes
so long but it that's sort of why some
of these get established
um it finally worked out that at least
there'd be a study committee well that
didn't get very far and that's why it
became a commission but we cannot find
I've got the working from now back but
we cannot find that original
material to get this commission study
committee recognition going backwards in
time we can't find it anywhere
so if if you could
perform a miracle it would be helpful
it would just helped us to decide you
know what else if these people really
wanted in the beginning besides
recognition what you know we we couldn't
find testimony
or minutes from that hearing and we
couldn't even find the original bill
it's got to be somewhere in our records
there's been a lot of recent testimonies
yeah
in the Edna committee so maybe that's a
place to start recently
yeah it's Jim you had to come in
uh yes thank you Mr chairman so
returning to the question of sort of
what
committees would each of these
committees or commissions belong to I
think that the this this section current
committees and commissions actually
has done that for a lot of these because
it has the an originating committee and
a house committee with jurisdiction
and a corresponding state agency for
what that's worth but
um yeah it's the it's the section that's
called current committees and
commissions and it's kind of it's in
landscape mode so I think a good deal of
that is already done
um I guess my question is are there
other data points that we want to add to
this so presumably there is a
spreadsheet or a word table or something
that contains this information that
there is a a column that says is is the
are they meeting still
it might be interesting to to know when
was the last time they met if we know
that it might be interesting to know
um if they have any members if they have
a chair if they have a quorum of members
appointed so I asked so I guess I asked
Dan while she was before she gets
started I said I was looking at the
spreadsheet I said there's a lot of
blank spaces for the meetings still I
said we that's a that's an important
piece of data that seems to be missing
in many ways I I guess so so a list of
members would be one thing but I I guess
my suggestion is that we work off of
this and see
answer the question what other data
points would we like to see
um I've mentioned a few I think it would
be also also be helpful to know
which members you know who are the
members if there are any of these
commissions currently if we know some of
those folks sometimes we can get a
clearer picture just by you know picking
up the phone and saying hey tell me
about this this commission
we want to bring them in right query
them we'll know who to ask to come
forward right I know get them scheduled
Deborah Childs had asked me about a
commission that I served on very briefly
last biennium and I I think I was able
to kind of give her off the top of my
head information that probably wasn't
written down anywhere but that
essentially it was that the the
commission had completed its work so
um so I think if we if we can come up
with the additional data points and
build out from what we have here that
would be a helpful starting point for
this
communities that started in so all right
so you you know I'm sorry
so you know what we're talking about in
the in the notebook
foreign
it's on page one of twelve
so so as part of that effort to do the
mapping we we you need to identify who
the chair is
of that committee that shouldn't be that
hard and then and then we can you know
at least be it and as as uh
representative Koval mentioned
perhaps an explosion of of the of the
spreadsheet as to who is on that
committee not just the chair but it's a
chair that over oversees the committee
but here are the 10 or 12 members that
are on the committee and that gives us a
source of people to call
not only to ask questions to but also to
invite in to testify
I guess
yes legislative members but that would
be the priority but also anyone else
that's still
uh listed as a member of the commission
we should maybe maybe is at two levels
of a spreadsheet maybe you if you
clicked on the on the thing then you'd
have a drop down menu
as to who all the people on commission
Mr chairman yeah that's what I was
getting at in the very beginning of this
section of the notebook for example on
the first page
um
you see a whole column are they meeting
still what year were they were
established right right I mean so one of
them advisory committee on brother
analyzer
um machines established in 1988 we don't
even know if they're still meeting right
things like that you need to know that
and why they're not meeting yeah those
if you can help fill those dates in as
to are they meetings still if the answer
is no then you know it doesn't it
doesn't uh indict anybody just let's
gives us information they're not meeting
and then it's going to be up to us to
call
uh on the committee chair and probably
uh if it's a car if it's the safety uh
commission why why isn't this meeting
and they think well we don't really need
it or whatever okay that's good
information for us
to deal with yes ma'am
thank you Mr chair I'm I'm wondering if
there's more information
it looks to me like there's more
information in the report from November
1st 2020. this is Karen's that Karen's
exactly Karen's rather thick memo
there's a whole um
section of that spreadsheet that has a
lot of information about
weather in 2020 they thought that it
should be kept
and I think I feel like
covet or no covid I I bet that the
information from 2020 is pretty relevant
to us for today because it it might be a
really good place to start because it
might be that some of the places in this
other spreadsheet that are empty I'm not
sure if if they're all filled in with
the data that's
um that's also in Karen's
right report from 2020. it's just it's
much more up to date you're right I'm
very hopeful that Karen will be here at
the next meeting because I think that
she can help explain the current status
yeah and you know
for example you might want to say gee
here's a committee that hasn't met in 12
years but there's a recommendation to
keep it why oh because of XYZ and so
forth oh okay I mean that
that explanation I think would really
help us make some decisions
hey John how are you
okay
I told you I'd be late
Wendy's the worst day of the week for me
and uh like I said our
other
mission do you set will not be here yeah
I have one I hear it
okay so uh yes ma'am I have the question
actually as I'm looking at this the
appendix from representative evil church
so since I was 2020 we know a lot of
things
these throughout all these
recommendations do we know what happened
with it did anything happen with any of
them they just or they just sit at a
recommendation stage
like what did the repeals go into it you
know it's recommending key for repeal or
right I assume nothing happened that way
because that's a great thing happened
already
repealed right
okay
huh okay so is this I feel like we have
like a spreadsheet issue where they're
needing to combine what we have or
cross-reference what we because maybe
between those two maybe a lot of these
have been repealed and we need to narrow
down what hasn't been
and I know that's one bucket in the
other bucket is the process going
forward especially if they have been
repealed it would would make sense for
us to spend a lot yeah I don't want to
waste time going through a chart that
you know that we don't need to
subtracting down do that
um yeah so maybe he wants to starting
with the 2020 right chart and finding
out or
finding out which of those were actually
enacted in terms of the report you're
talking about the the one the E what
I'll call the evil yeah from January
30th 2020.
uh
the January
the memo is for November but I'm looking
into the
the appendix B appendix
so for your edification we're looking at
the the middle one of the middle tabs
that's titled
past committee on committee reports and
there's a couple of lengthy memos in
there from uh author probably by Karen
Ebel uh one stated January 30th and one
shaded dated November 1st 2020.
and Karen evil is the uh
identified uh author of both of those so
just as a point of reference as you're
looking through the book that's what
we're talking about right to the
November 1 memo and you reference at
1240 HP 12 45 this would be sort of the
most recent work right or or
recollection
so can I add I I think that that is the
one with the most data but this
spreadsheet the smaller one in landscape
says it was updated April 10th
as of April 10th of this year
so I wonder does it reflect the repeals
that you mentioned Brad do you know
this one apple tab is that again oh yeah
the tab is current committees
and commissions
because what I what I am what I wasn't
very clear about articulating is I I
think this landscape spreadsheet might
be
up to date on
what we have now and what the Committees
are now
um and the committee with jurisdiction
right I I just think there might be a
little bit more information
different information
in Karen's report that tells us like
that they thought something should be
kept and maybe a little bit about why so
maybe adding that piece so Karen's
question might be
for example if Karen had recommended to
be repealed
did it fought and it was repealed did it
fall off of the spreadsheet
.com
that would be good it's so
so the one of the issues is going to be
is if we look at the recommendations
uh 2020 that Karen came up with
how many of them or which ones of them
were successfully accomplished so that
the spreadsheet
which would reflect on the accuracy and
the up-to-date datedness that's a term
of the spreadsheet
that you know don't worry about this
particular
subcommittee because it's already been
repealed so don't spend any time on it
was
outside
right that's that's a good that'd be
very helpful thank you
so good ideas both of them I appreciate
that
uh as we start digging into this we're
going to find more of that I think
and if there are those
committees I I think I mentioned this uh
last week if there are those committees
that look like they're important like
that one we talked about the peace ass
committee that Thomas Sherman
in the Senate was looking after if that
if that if that's going to be a
a hill that he wants to die on
uh then my recommendation is we step
back because we're not going to get
anywhere anyway they'll they'll kill
that legislation let's spend our time on
something that
both houses agree that it's time to end
it and uh and put it in the
accomplish
column yes thank you chairman I think
it'd be interesting for us to consider
um
requiring commissions to determine their
own fate
you know like are there things that we
could be doing to basically say we're
not taking immediate action to dissolve
this commission however
if you're still going to continue
here's what you need to meet these
minimum requirements and that those
minimum requirements stay in place for
the future and that are things that
we're considering before we even
establish it in the first place
that's good that's a that's a I think
that's a good idea that's a good process
issue
you know if that oh by the way here's
your first notice we're looking at this
here's the second notice we're getting
ready to
right repeal legislation
uh you you better come forward and talk
us out of it if you really think it
needs to uh to stay or whatever yes
ma'am thank you Mr chairman and thank
you very much Mr leader
um
that goes along with the final reports
on some of these Commissions in terms of
recommendations for what should happen
if the commission's inactive or if
they've stalled or if they seem to be
going in a different direction because
each commission is given a charge as to
what they're supposed to do
and we need to know if they are sticking
to that or if they're just going off
willy-nilly in some other direction I
can't imagine that they do but who knows
when someone's meeting for off and on
for 10 or 15 or 20 years I mean I can't
believe they're sticking to the original
charge so we need to know the thank you
who else have any uh comments uh or
ideas that you might want to throw on
the table
maybe this is a process point for
putting in place structure When Future
commissions are considered by a house
but
I just it seems that there should be a
default sense you know if you haven't
met in x amount of time where you
haven't submitted a report but that's it
it ends and then and there could be an
appeal process maybe or something where
for circumstances that justify but I I
just think there needs that was part of
the process issue that I was talking
about last week that
that we we ought to think about I I
think we ought to think about that if if
a commission hasn't met an X number of
term next number of times in a row that
they go on the chopping block or if a
Committee Member doesn't show up X
number of times in a row for a meeting
then they're they're off the committee
and they need to be replaced things like
rules like that I think it seems to me
at least coming into the summer blindly
as they were saying before it seems like
the default right now is
in perpetuity you know there there are
no guard rails like that right
necessarily
um
or not not across the board at least so
that that seems like it would be
worthwhile to me to explore
yes sir
I I also wonder if uh
there should be a process for
dissolution I like is there like we we
can't put it on the committee chairs for
example like the standing committee
chairs to dissolve a like they don't
they don't have the statutory authority
to do that but should we establish
statutory Authority
to Sunset these more quickly that Sunset
isn't the right word but to dissolve a
commission uh if they aren't Meeting
those specific requirements I'm I'm way
more excited about the kind of proactive
like how do we manage this moving
forward then
been actually taking on the political
responsibility of saying we're chopping
all these you know we're going to get
rid of all these commissions but I do
think that there's a way that the two
can come to get that we can actually
establish the process
and then
quickly get rid of some of them that you
know aren't Meeting those minimum right
I think if you make it a if you haven't
met an x amount of time then it's not a
political there shouldn't
write that and it's just a
logistical issue not a prioritizing this
committee over that committee it should
be a trigger yeah yeah and and some of
them might be meeting some of that might
be filing reports you know maybe there
is a requirement if there isn't already
for you know the commissions to file
reports
um maybe there is a not to create a new
one but a uh you know maybe there's a
joint
uh legislative committee on commissions
that just meets quarterly and
you know is empowered by Statute to
do the cutting
and then it isn't house versus Senate
either it's something that we can do
together
can I ask you a question and your
suggestion so you're saying not so much
to take the time to go through every
single one of them to set up a procedure
going forward and they'll just they'll
just automatically either fall off or
stay on
according to the procedure that we come
up with I think that's a way that's a
way we could go
um which
I think that's I think that's impossible
I'm not I'm not saying that's the what
we should do but I think we should
consider it I like that solution I've
been told however
plant a plan forward has to be one at a
time legislative
piece of legislation for each commission
that we want to want to kill that's
that's what I've been told because we
have to undo what was done in the first
place
and that we can't there's there's no
Sunset clause or nothing that we can
take advantage of now I don't know
uh and you might know this but I don't
know if if maybe it's we approach the
rules committee to say that they can
help us come up with
language or uh the right to do what
we're talking about but right now I
don't think that right exists but we I'm
not sure that it can't exist and I don't
know that we can do it in house rules
because it we need to involve the senate
in some way right so that's where we
need we need to figure out how the two
come together
um
yes ma'am and agree with
with Mr leader and thank you Mr chairman
um if you if we can take time before our
next meeting to read the final reports
in here there's some pretty good
recommendations the previous committees
on commissions came up with and some of
what you've spoken with is in there and
part of what when you mentioned Sunset
Provisions that should be in the
original legislation I think OLS has
some responsibility here as well
um there's a lot they can't do they
can't tell us and advise us on previous
bills that have been put in but if we
read the final reports here
um members who are new can get guidance
from
orientation
members who have been here can get
guidance from their chairman
and go to OLS and these bills can be
drafted more specifically I was stunned
when I saw some of this to see that some
commissions are set up without details I
mean when I served on Judiciary we had
details for everything and we had Sunset
Provisions when it was important and we
had specific goals the commissions had
to meet
so except we ran into that problem as we
heard last week with the right to know
commission that dragged on and on it was
bulky too many people from too many
parts of the state never able to get a
quorum never able to fulfill their
responsibilities but continued so these
final reports have some very helpful
information and we can build upon that I
think yeah I I agree I I one of the
things when we get ready to tackle the
process pieces
uh I've already spoken to the OLS
attorneys and what they can they said
they could do they're a little nervous
but what they could do is they could
they could come up with statutory
language
that would serve as a template
that a legislate legislators that come
to them say I want to uh study
Commission on such and such they'd be
material they would be handed back to
them they that well we've been asked to
supply you with a template of how this
has to work and have Sunset Clauses in
it and all that stuff so
I've already talked to them about that
but that's something as a group we'd
have to decide that we want to do that
and what that step that template might
look like yeah now you want that yeah I
and I really like that idea I also think
that
um even though in order to take action
on each of these
commissions you'd have to do it
individually I wonder if we could we
could create
and maybe this is a question for OLS
could we once we've we've decided on the
template for how things are going to
work moving forward can we adjust all
the existing commissions
so that
those same
requirements are applied to the ones
that already exist and so I think it's
in my mind it would be a single Bill
something like a 1449 adjustment
yeah yeah and it just goes through and
it says here are the changes that we're
making to each of the commissions
because some of them may already have it
I mean it's a lot of work but what it
does is it brings everything
very easily
as a group decide that we want to
kill we want to repeal I just changed my
life if you want to repeal these 30
commissions and we and we all agree if
it's a 10 to nothing vote
in the second consent calendar
it would happen pretty fast now would it
go through the Senate
that's another question do we have
co-sponsors and all that stuff they're
there but that would that's also
available to us as a consent calendar so
we don't have to take this to a Fluff a
flawed discussion
and somebody for you know that sponsors
uh one of the Indian tribes gets all
emotional about it that uh say
you you know you watch the speaker is
there do we have a motion to accept the
consent calendar boom it's a ton but
not that we want to be sneaky about it
but that's that is available to us with
a lot less arguments yes yes sir and I
also think that we could come to the
conclusion that we want to put
these changes into the existing statutes
and that then puts all every Commission
on notice to say you need to meet these
minimum requirements so that we don't
need to put repeal
we don't we don't need to be the ones
deciding on which ones to reveal that
there's some self-selection or if we see
that there it makes sense to merge some
of these or I don't know what the other
you know legislative remedies might be
but
um it allows us to do that and I hope
that we could come to a strong
bipartisan consensus I think so too I I
think that uh
in fact a lot of the uh
a lot of the uh selection to be on this
committee was
having a bipartisan uh predisposition
going into it so that's
that's a compliment to you all it was
you were thought in that that regard yes
John okay thank you Mr chair uh going
along with representative wilhelm's idea
I was I was going through this and I
actually was sitting there online
looking at some of the bills and making
up like a checklist on basically how you
do a presentation who what why where
when how you know all those questions
and you look through the through these
commissions they don't answer all the
questions and like I said use the
standard create a standard form and if
they don't answer the questions
fill out the fill out the form so they
do it they do answer the questions you
know when do they meet who is it why why
are they there what are they doing
what's their Charter how are they doing
it do they meet every month do they meet
every quarter
it it'll and they'll answer all that
you'll have a checklist that everybody
can go through as they if they want to
create a commission you know is it
sunset right right on the bottom is it
sunsetting yes it must be sunset and or
it must be like a five-year review if
it's a really good commission you go
into review and you know you justify
what you're doing and say okay you're
good for another five years you know
like some of these commissions are
really really important and they do good
work but the some of the ones that are
that are like uh you know one year two
year they have a specific very tight
question that they're answering and
they're done
so yeah I think that's a great idea I'm
almost I'm a big fan of standardization
so that would definitely fill the bill
all right so uh yes
and it's evil
I mean she's
she's already gone through this several
terms in maybe when she's here the next
meeting she probably has a good idea
which ones should be repealed which ones
should stay so yeah I think that getting
her input yeah
this uh meeting today early
uh
but I think
per the next time if she comes next time
let's have an understanding that we're
probably going to go run over because
we're going to spend spend some time
going through the things that she's we
need to take advantage of her
institution bring in the laundry list
I'm gonna try a Target that we get out
of here by noon today anybody reject to
that no
um
so you guys you guys
our assistants here you guys understand
what we're looking for uh and is are we
being reasonable that that by next
Monday we could have something to look
at oh two weeks school vacation week
next week
well that's a good question do we do we
want to skip a week and meet in two
weeks so do we want to try to find
another day
yeah
okay so we made first to be our next
meeting
and I will be late I told you when is
the worst day I have standing
appointments Monday mornings so we made
me eat longer and I'll still be here
yes yeah I would say on May 1st plan on
maybe two o'clock
until two yeah I think it's gonna be a
lot of long morning
yeah okay I I've spoken to Karen a
couple of times
uh informally and she's
she's bubbling over with all kinds of
information that we can take advantage
of
yes ma'am
um we have a little time I know but I
wanted to ask if
are there assignments that we think we
could be working on in the interim are
there things as Mr chairman there are
tasks you'd like any of us to be
particularly
giving thought or drafting I don't I
don't know if we're there yet I was
thinking in the two weeks or are there
things we could be doing well I
uh yes and no first of all it's
important for us to become intimately
familiar with the three ring buying is
in front of us to go through I mean we
were giving it to us last week and
hopefully over the past weekend we we
flipped through it but I think we need
to get an intimate knowledge of of it
write down the questions that you have
in in the margins and come to the next
meeting ready to ask you questions of
our researchers and our more experienced
members like like Karen
that have been through the company when
I think representative wall you've been
through some degree yes I just want to
add on that please do take time it
doesn't take that long to read through
this notebook and those final reports of
very very helpful
and that can help us develop our
concepts of where we might want to go
because they have laid out some
groundwork some of which as I said has
been good and has been followed through
and some of which it's just been out
there and no one's done much so I must
have been so very helpful thank you I'm
sorry to your question I think that if
any of us have some real solid ideas
about process changes to start making
note of those and bring them with you to
the next meeting about
what do you do when you sit with uh with
OLS and you're trying to start up a
commission uh what do we do when we
think we want to repeal something
what are the steps what are the six
steps we go through in order to appeal
uh getting information getting
current members to testify
uh so and the other thing to think about
is when our assistants bring us back
that
that spreadsheet was that has all the
mapping
in it what do we want to do next do we
want to
bring those committee chairs in to talk
to them one at a time or two or three at
a time or uh
or what you know what do we do with the
information that we're about to get so
we don't have to wait a meeting to
decide
to think about it so I would say come to
the the uh the meeting in the first
meeting in May with those thoughts uh
matured a little bit uh say well I think
we ought to do this this and this and
then we then we can talk about it and we
can make some decisions as opposed to
just uh initiating discussion
that sound sound reasonable
it almost sounds like for our thinking
purposes having like a float if I I
might try to play around with it like
coming up with a rough flow chart you
know for those sorts of questions any of
the process the processes
process issues
I could in some cases a decision tree
and it has the
has the commission been
sponsored by the
Senate yes I know if it's if it answers
yes you know who sponsored it and then
we get a Target if we're gonna go
uh kill
uh repeal
Tom Sherman's committee we better go
talk to him first and that ought to be
in the list of things to do in the
decision tree have you spoken to the
sponsor or whatever because we don't
want to go through all that effort and
have him uh talk to his his comrades in
the Senate and say we want to kill this
thing coming over from the house oh our
time will be wasted I'd rather spend it
on something that
more likely to pass than something we
know is going to get killed
and how about you guys but
yes John uh also uh I agree with you
that you should read through this which
I did that's why I was wandering through
it and things that were of interest to
you know each of us you know pick out
okay legislative youth advisory Council
take a look at what it is and see who's
on it and it says keep amend appointing
languages and see if there's
places in there where it can be amended
that's where uh represented evil is
going to be able to help us because
she's probably got a whole
list well what's what our researchers
are going to help us
that that's all potentially old data
yeah uh there's a another spreadsheet
well I got I got you know I got I got
both of everybody because on that
spreadsheet
this position may have already been made
yes something may have been and it
decided to be kept or decided to be
repealed and they would if it's been
repealed it would have should have
fallen off this spreadsheet a couple of
tabs down so we don't want to spend a
lot of time on something that's already
been repealed
agree but see if if it says uh
amend to designate one of the house
members from Public Works assistant 2016
and see you know just go in and see was
it done
you know and if it wasn't make you can
make a little list
yeah with Cameron's with Cameron uh
expertise on this
I agree
but like I said I sit there nothing
better to do and just go in and look at
these things
yes ma'am
thank you I think too some of those um
things that you're talking about those
amendments in repeal I think we'll find
in um
1269 that's right behind those reports I
think instead of instead of doing all
that in separate bills it looks like
they've tried to do a lot of it in the
same bill
so
we can probably even cross-reference for
ourselves
um
you know like
there's stuff about the public water
access Advisory Board the legislative
oversight committee on delivery of Life
Services they tried to kind of put all
that stuff into 1269.
so that would be a helpful way to see
that they
went through and tried to make the
changes that were recommended in that
previous report too right and what Karen
can help us with is I try to do just
that on this particular bill it didn't
work because of
I ran into a stone wall with this
particular commit you know those types
of insights that will be very valuable
to us to help us be guided as to how
we're going to attack an issue because
if those stone walls are still present
it's going to be my advice to the
committee as we walk around the stone
wall and work on something else
right but I don't want to I don't think
we should spend our time banging our
head on this stuff on the wall
that's why I said I think yet last week
if there are
what I called sacred cows probably a bad
term there are those types of things
that
one caucus versus the other decides this
is really important to our caucus that
we just leave it alone and let it stay
and not to fight it then
there's enough
for us to work on without
getting into a fight with each other
they'll be curious to the neighboring to
see and I'm not as knowledgeable yet
about what which of those commit which
committees those may be but also if they
actually have been meeting or have had
enough memory you know they're ideally
if they're important if they are those
sorts of importance they have actually
been getting towards those goals but
we'll see I guess
um from Karen's notes especially I know
there was for as an example there was
there was a one I'm on Matt and I are
both on Edna as a second committee I
don't know how many euros that's at
least one additional one that we're on
we came up uh an issue of a study
Commission on
um statistics
about
uh race
background and all that stuff that it's
a it's it's been around for a while but
we also found that UNH does all this
work for us for free and I said let's
let them do it and not employ a study
commission to do that so that we we
repealed that in the in committee that I
think I'm not sure the status I think
it's made it through
the consent calendar I don't know
uh status with the Senate what they did
with it if anything yet but those are
the types of things that I think
you know those are in my view
no-brainers but they may be emotional
for somebody to say hey wait a minute
we're going to get the data it's just
going to come this in this case from the
from UNH uh as opposed to uh
a legislative committee
I I just think the makeup of this
committee given in the term that we're
in and the you know the equal numbers of
Republicans and Democrats is a really
exciting opportunity for us to really
zero in on the ones that need to be
right right you know removed so if we do
make that decision I'm confident that
we'll be able to you know discern these
are the ones that we shouldn't be
touching because frankly
you know it may it may result in an
entire caucus deciding to oppose right
what we put forward
um and if there's something on the
Democratic side that they've got a
problem with and problem on the
Republican side they have a problem with
then all of our work is going to be for
not right right it's going to
contaminate I think the process
okay uh any final thoughts yes uh Jim
you had something uh yeah but so so I
want to add that
the the
possibility of a commit of a of a
committee or commission being repealed
um may be enough to prompt
some action to get it back in gear so I
appreciate and agree with what you said
um but I also think that we need to say
that for those that are being maintained
going forward there's going to be an
expectation that those those committees
and commissions are doing their job
anywhere if this processes are saying
look it might be
even happen and it triggers people to
get back into action I mean that's right
you know so I do really like the idea of
bringing in the statutory committee
chairs in some way just because I mean I
I can only speak to Transportation but I
feel like when
we have bills in front of us that seem
stuck on it's like well let's maybe
we'll make a study committee uh and and
I think our chair is pretty cognizant of
trying to say let's not do a throwaway
here but I think the more buy-in we have
from Community chairs and I realized
chairmanships change but
um I think will benefit committee work
too in terms of
whether Community Health committees
really weigh is this worth do we need
a study committee here um
I just think having that communication
would be productive right I I think that
uh you're right I and I think that
too often we use
study
uh committees or commissions as a as a
disposition
that allows us to walk away from
something with without much pain
but yet that thing lingers on for us
sometimes years uh and it's it's a it's
a mindset and again if we if we get some
accountability with the committee
chairman that if if they're gonna elect
something in their committee go into a
study and they're going to have to
manage it that may be less likely to do
it
gives them
I want to see cover but it gives them a
basis just just
set those expectations in committee and
say look I you know
if I'm going to support those or want us
to move forward with this these are the
standards we're gonna have to meet their
accountability standards now you know
maybe there were different than they
were in the past
exactly
John you anything you want to add
I always have something I was I was I
was thinking
it's now on some of the Committees that
you know are a little sketchy
you know don't come you know invite him
in
and
ask the chairman
how are things going
do you guys need any help
do you need us to do something to help
you be successful
you know don't point a finger you know
give them a hand give them a handout
to see and maybe they'll go yeah we you
know the members don't come uh you know
we have an agenda that we'd like to
accomplish but nobody comes to the
meetings and how and how can we help you
become more successful now they had the
guy might the chair might be really
driven but nobody wants to work nobody
wants to do stuff so let's help them
become successful
instead of you know no they're not doing
anything so let's kill them Let's help
them be successful say okay we're gonna
we're gonna help you and you know you
got two years to to
you'll get in and I think you'd be
surprised some of these some of these
guys are going to be
quote
in response to that
um sometimes it's helpful to
put a commission to rest and
re-establish something else and go in
another Direction that's more productive
to help these groups along and help them
be as productive as they need and want
to be thank you
do we really want a 15-person commission
across many state agencies or with a
three-person legislative
study group accomplished the same and
much faster and less a lot less cost to
the government
we've got a lot of options
you do I mean I'd rather help getting
the handout to to help them resistant
it's just you're such a nice guy
last Republicans training all these
handouts
but we're not taxing them all right all
right let's let's let's uh let's call it
and uh appreciate uh your time let's
plan on a longer meeting the next time
we get together in two weeks so yeah
from ten to two all right
first
and if
you can help encourage
Karen's attendance because of how
important
okay great
foreign